Hey guys. I'm Abbey Sharpe welcome to another edition of Fertility Files here on Abbey's Kitchen.
Today we'll be talking about a topic that we all love to hate our period
And, guys, before you click next you might actually learn something about the women in your life,
so I do encourage you to maybe stick around. Now, real talk friends
women of childbearing age are no stranger to the cramps,
cravings, and mood swings that come with the dreaded time of the month. I've received a lot of questions about this,
so today I'm gonna be breaking down the research on the best things to eat during each phase of your
cycle, so that we can all feel our best. Now before we get into it
of course
my general disclaimer that the information in this video is for
education and entertainment purposes only,
and you should always speak to a registered dietitian or your health care provider about your unique case.
Okay so let's get into it by starting with the first phase of the menstrual cycle
the follicular phase. Day 1 of the cycle is marked by the arrival of our favorite red frenemy our
monthly period. Now, this phase involves the shedding of the uterine lining, and depending on your cycle, this may last for approximately
3 to 6 days.
I think we can all agree that we aren't feeling too hot during this phase. Aside from the sexy crime scene in our pants,
we typically feel super tired, sluggish, and
experience painful cramps that make us want to call in sick and chill in the field position for the day.
And who exactly is to blame for all of these emotional and physical changes? Our fluctuating hormones of course.
At this stage of our cycle the hormones progesterone and estrogen are at their lowest which explains the low energy and overall
sluggishness that women tend to experience. So what can we do from a nutritional standpoint to ease the effects of this phase?
Tip number one - up that iron. Iron is a really important mineral that helps produce red blood cells and
transports oxygen throughout the body. Because of menstrual blood losses,
iron deficiency is one of the most common nutritional deficiencies among women of childbearing age.
Lower iron levels during menstruation also explains why women typically have low energy and fatigue.
Therefore women must compensate for the amount of blood being lost from their period by eating more iron rich foods during this time.
So iron rich animal sources include foods like red meat, poultry and fish, and
plant-based sources include fortified cereals, tofu, beans, lentils, and other legumes. Tip number two -
pair it with vitamin C. Vitamin C is an antioxidant that not only helps with immunity,
healthy skin, and wound healing but also helps our bodies to absorb iron even better. Think of vitamin C as iron's
trusty sidekick or cheerleader that brings out the best in them.
So if you're adding an iron rich meal during that time of the month,
make sure to pair it with a source of vitamin C like citrus fruits or veggies like bell peppers,
tomatoes or leafy greens. To give you an example, this could look as easy as a bowl of veggie chili
with a squeeze of lime juice on top or tofu stir-fry with bell peppers.
It's actually an intuitive pairing because these foods just kind of taste good together and
It just proves how smart the body truly is. Tip number three - go decaf.
Just as vitamin C helps to increase the absorption of iron,
there are also certain inhibitors to be aware of that can interfere with iron absorption.
Coffee and caffeinated teas, such as green tea and black tea, have an antioxidant substance called polyphenols
which can decrease the amount of iron the body absorbs.
The other potential downside to caffeine is that it's a vasoconstrictor,
which means it makes the blood vessels in your body
constrict. A lot of women find that this constriction can make their period cramps even worse.
So for that reason it might be best to stick to herbal tea on those first few days, or at the very least
spread the caffeine out at least an hour before or after your iron rich meal to help maximize the absorption of iron.
Tip number four - get plant powered. A lot of women find that their cramps in these early days of this phase
so debilitating that they have a really hard time enjoying a full meal.
This is also the time when our bloating and cramps start. So making sure to stay nourished with lighter,
less processed food may help. While salt and fat are both super delicious,
you probably inherently know that this isn't probably going to make you feel so great right now because we're already feeling so bloated,
sluggish, and sick. Salt increases water retention which causes bloating and fatty foods increase
prostaglandin production which can increase contractions aka cramps.
So I would really try to focus on recipes with lots of veggies and fruit,
especially those that are rich in hydrating water and energizing carbs to help with your waning energy levels.
Plus a little bit of some whole grains and legumes. Meals in this phase do not need to be fancy or Instagrammable.
I mean, you're probably really tired and just feel like crap.
So be kind to yourself and focus on super simple meals with whole ingredients whenever you can.
Tip 5 - Take a walk.
Okay, so during those first few days of your period and the days that follow, your estrogen and progesterone levels are pretty low.
So your stamina might not be so great.
But there is some evidence that a little light gentle exercise may play a therapeutic role in
relieving cramps by releasing endorphins which helps improve your mood and relax the body.
Exercise may also provide a distraction from the discomfort of the cramps.
So that also is always a good thing. This may or may not be helpful for everyone depending on the severity of your cramps,
but it doesn't hurt to try. Okay, let's jump into Phase two of the menstrual cycle - Ovulation.
Now at this phase, a new egg begins the process of preparing its descent down the fallopian
tubes to enter the uterus in hopes of meeting a nice little sperm to settle down with. This phase is met with an
increase in estrogen, testosterone,
follicle stimulating hormone, and luteinizing hormone, which explains why we feel more energized at this point.
So take advantage of this increase in libido, sexual
energy and mood now is your time to work.
Tip one - Move in a way that feels good. Because your energy levels are now a lot more balanced in this phase,
you're probably feeling more excited to hit the gym.
So hit up some Pilates, weight training, spin class, or what I guess evolution would want us to be doing of course
having sex. Our higher energy levels and brighter mood are a good match for these types of moderate to high intensity
activities. So if you are an active person and this brings you joy, now is the time for it. Tip number two - use
this energy to prep. Again, because this phase allows for optimal energy levels
this is the best time to get in the kitchen and cook up a storm.
So get out your slow-cooker, instant pot, and every casserole dish you own.
This is when you want to do your batch prepping for the week.
So chopping up vegetables, cooking proteins, making freezed soups and casseroles for the week.
Go get'em girl.
Now,
let's talk about the third and final phase of the menstrual cycle,
the luteal phase. The luteal phase happens when ovulation phase does not result in fertilization
Aka there ain't no bun in the oven.
When this happens, hormone levels decline and we experience the oh so lovely PMS. This may include symptoms like cramps, headaches,
bloating, mood swings, fatigue, and food cravings. Which brings me to tip number one -
notice your food cravings. Now, we have all been there
you know, eating chocolate chip cookies and crying over a cheesy rom-com for no real
reason. That, my friends, is the luteal phase aka when PMS hits. But food cravings symptoms are actually
scientifically proven. Research has found our food cravings during the luteal phase are linked to the amount of leptin in our blood.
Leptin is the hunger hormone that tells us when we're full and we can stop eating. Studies have actually shown that there may be a
relationship between leptin and
estrogen hormones and the food cravings that we experience. When leptin and estrogen levels are high during the luteal phase,
women tend to experience increased cravings
particularly for sweet carb rich foods. However, when leptin and estrogen levels are low
women may experience fewer cravings. Now, we may not be able to change our leptin or estrogen levels,
but what we can do is listen to our bodies and notice our cravings and any patterns that arise during this phase of menstruation.
Do you crave sweet foods or salty foods? Are there certain textures that you prefer? maybe a
satisfying crunch from a bag of chips or the soft doughiness from a doughnut?
I mean, it's really important
we start to become more aware and mindful of these food cravings in order to assess what it is that your body actually needs.
And that brings me to tip number two -
Let yourself have the carbs. As mentioned, research suggests that we tend to crave
Refined carbs during this phase, thanks to PMS. And trust me,
I am all for enjoying that cookie or bowl of chocolate ice cream.
But this is a long-ass phase of our cycle and when we're about to lead ourselves into an even more sluggish phase aka
Our period right after, I figure it's ideal to have some really good fuel on board.
Also, restricting all the carbs right when you're craving them
the most is just going to kick off a massive cookie binge and that is just not gonna leave us feeling too hot either.
Now is the time to focus on slow burning but delicious carbs.
Maybe make a big batch of overnight oats for breakfast, pick up a hearty seedy bread for lunch, or
roast some sweet potatoes with a little bit of maple syrup and cinnamon for dinner. And when in doubt,
pair that carb with a source of protein and fat to keep those blood sugar
levels even keeled. Tip number three - up the fiber. On a similar note, let's talk about fiber.
Progesterone levels are at an all-time high
during this phase right before your period, and we know that progesterone is one of the major culprits of
constipation. So you're gonna want to sneak in lots of fiber rich whole grains like quinoa, or bran cereal, things like berries,
or vegetables like broccoli or kale,
flax, beans, and nuts. That brings me to tip number four - ease the bloat.
During the luteal phase of menstruation and leading in to those first few days of our period, it's very common feel bloated
regardless of how much or what you eat thanks to our higher levels of estrogen. And those estrogen levels cause us to retain more water.
Therefore, as I mentioned earlier with the menstrual phase, you'll want to focus on more fresh foods instead of highly processed
salty foods.
You might also want to to plain water as carbonated drinks can cause more gas and discomfort
plus going easy on foods that tend to cause you digestive distress. This obviously varies from person to person, but common triggers are
high FODMAP foods like dairy, apples, wheat, and beans.
Gassy veggies like broccoli and kale,
sugar alcohols and booze. If you do have a higher sodium meal and are feeling a little bit uncomfortable, don't sweat it.
I mean you can pair it with foods that are rich in water like cucumber,
lettuce and citrus, or potassium rich foods like bananas and sweet potatoes to help balance out the salt.
Bottom line, us ladies deal with our monthly period every month, so we are totally experts right now.
In fact, you're probably doing a lot of these things without even thinking about them because they intuitively just feel good.
But if you're finding some of your symptoms at different times of the month totally throwing you off,
I hope this video gives you some evidence-based ideas on how you can feel your best no matter what your hormones throw at you.
Well folks, that is all for today. As always, if you like this video be sure to give it a thumbs up,
leave me a comment below if you have any fertility, reproductive, or hormonal health questions.
Subscribe to the channel, and I'll see you next time on Abbey's Kitchen. Bye!